[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
70 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing
very well, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm doing
pretty good, pretty good.
Still second week of
relaxing time after Next,
you know, feeling relaxed,
planning on new stuff.
Today we have a very
cool interviewer
that we're rescuing from the
Cloud Next 2017 conference
floor.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We got
the chance to meet--
well, actually, I
had met him before,
but I don't think
you met him before.
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so we
met with Brad Rydzweski, who
is the creator of Drone
CI, and we got the chance
to talk about how it works.
And Drone CI is, for
those that don't know,
it's a continuous integration
continuous deployment platform
that is based on containers.
And since Jessie Frazelle
was walking around--
MARK MANDEL: --she was
just around, we figured
we'd just pull her
in and be like, hey,
you want to come join us?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so she joined us.
So we have to then interview
with both Brad Rydzewski
and Jessie Frazelle,
which was pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: It
was pretty awesome.
And once we're done
with that, we've
got our question of the week
all about pro-aborts protobuffs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Why should
we use protocol buffers?
Why is this thing cool?
And what is it useful for?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and the question
is actually coming
from someone that
came to meet us at the GCP
Podcast booth at Cloud Next,
so all Cloud Next
related things today.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
So, before we get into our
interviews and the questions
of the week, why don't we
talk through our cool things
of the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so the
first one that you brought
is for Google Cloud
Dataflow, which I love.
It's an amazing platform to
basically do flows of data.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
big streaming piles
of data and doing
real-time analytics or ETL
or all sorts of other fun stuff
to it as it comes through.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
only thing I didn't like
is that you have to
write Java for it.
And I've done it, but
it's not the case anymore.
MARK MANDEL: Well, so you
could write Python on Dataflow
for a while, but it is
now generally available.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So you
can go hack on that
and you have SLAs and
all the good stuff,
which is pretty cool.
So you can build pipelines on,
say, Apache Beam as well, which
is the open source version
of Dataflow, within Python
as well as doing them
directly on Dataflow
until you can do
all your data needs
and analytic needs on
Dataflow using Python
under general availability.
Go have at it, and
have lots of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice, and
if you're more interested
on Dataflow, we had an
episode-- episode number 30--
where we talked about
gaming analytics
and we talked a little
bit more in detail
what Dataflow, but I
guess that at some point
we should do an
episode on Dataflow.
MARK MANDEL: We should.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: As soon
as they get support for Go.
Hello.
Anyway, the second cool
thing of the week--
actually, the second
and the third one
are related both to SQL.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So this one's mine too.
So this is kind of cool.
This was a blog post that's
on the Big Data and Machine
Learning Blog talking
about how you can use R--
I have to think about that
because I'm Australian,
I can't say "ahh", I say "arr"--
R, the programming
language, commonly used
for scientific, numerical,
analytic, statistical, data
crunching and providing
plots and whatnot
for that data, how
to connect that up
to Cloud SQL mySQL edition
so that you can pull data out
of your Cloud SQL systems and
do statistical analysis on it,
build graphs, build diagrams--
all that cool stuff.
So your you data scientists
can have loads of fun
with your Cloud SQL data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I have two jokes.
Do you know what's the
favorite language of pirates?
MARK MANDEL: Arr.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And, do you
know how to say R in Spanish?
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: [Spanish R].
MARK MANDEL: Oh!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Try it.
[Spanish R] That's
actually not--
MARK MANDEL: Is that all right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: You'll take it?
All right!
Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK,
so the last cool thing
of the week for today is, again,
Cloud SQL but this PostgreSQL
is not MySQL.
As you know, we announced
that during Cloud Next.
And there's a blog post written
about how you can use it
for geospatial applications.
And I think it's very
interesting because it actually
comes from our friends
in the [? calc ?] labs.
Yeah, we had them before.
We had them,
specifically, one episode
we had Tim Kelton on episode 41.
And they do a lot of really
cool things with maps.
And now they're talking about
how they actually do these
and how do the queries
about, like, oh, how do
I find these things in the map?
Storing old information on
PostgreSQL with Cloud SQL.
So it's a very
interesting blog post
with a lot of really interesting
detail, a lot of cool graphs
and maps and diagrams.
So if you're interested
in geospatial applications
and specifically SQL, MySQL or
PostgreSQL, go check it out!
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't we go chat with
our friends Brad and Jessie
and see what they're up to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let's do that.
We are now joined by Brad
Rydzewski here on, still,
the floor of Cloud Next in
Moscone West in San Francisco--
beautiful California--
and I'm very happy
to welcome here.
Hello Brad, how are you doing?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Very
good, thank you.
Thanks for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you for coming.
Why are you here?
Who are you?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Well, OK,
yeah, so I'm an open source
developer I work primarily
on an open source
project called Drone.
It focuses on container-based
continuous delivery.
So it integrates with
Google Cloud Platform.
And many of my open
source community members
use Google Cloud Platform.
So it's a great opportunity
to be here and learn
about the platform.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
I'm also pretty excited, and
I have to admit something--
I'm a huge fan of yours.
We have a guest host here,
as well, Jessie Frazelle.
How are you doing?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: I'm good.
I just gave my talk so
now I'm super relaxed.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, basically we
decided that we are
going to be talking
a little bit about
containers at some point,
so in case we say
anything wrong,
Jessie can shout
at us or something.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
totally OK with that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
let's talk a little bit
more about Drone.
You said it is a continuous
delivery product or service.
What is it exactly?
What is the difference with
others like Travis or Jenkins?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Sure, I think
the biggest difference is
that Drone is built
from the ground up
to use containers as the
build runtime, specifically,
right now, it uses Docker.
So every single build and
build step executes in a Docker
container itself and
the configuration
is defined as a superset
of the Docker Compose Yml.
So it's really a
container-first solution.
MARK MANDEL: So this project,
is it open source, is it hosted?
What's the idea there?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yeah, it's
completely open source,
it's on GitHub, you can find
it at GitHub.com/drone/drone.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome, but drones
are also a business as well.
Is that correct?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yeah,
so it started out
as a subscription
service similar to a lot
of the other ones out
there, but right now we
focus mostly on open source
and on premise and enterprise.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, and
before we get into the details
on how it is implemented,
what's the name Drone?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: The
idea with the name Drone
came from this idea
that it was automated,
that you had something
controlling and executing
your builds in an
automated fashion,
from a central source
like that Borg source.
I think that's a name you guys
are familiar with at Google.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Borg?
Yeah, maybe.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: The name
came like five years ago,
maybe when it was a little
less of a controversial term
and then it just kind of stuck.
And domain names
are hard to come by,
so I just wasn't interested
in changing at that point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
let's talk a little bit more
about exactly how Drone works.
Like you said, it's
an open source project
so you can run it anywhere.
Where are people running it?
How do you run it?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Sure,
well drone is built in Go,
so it compiles down to
a nice small binary that
has no external
runtime dependencies.
It ships in like a 15
megabyte Docker scratch
image, so it's really
easy to get up and running
and you can really
run it anywhere
you want on any cloud
within your data center
on your own infrastructure.
It's a really portable system.
MARK MANDEL: Now, I think
we were talking about
as well before the episode--
most people run it on Kubernetes
or a lot of people do?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yeah, I mean,
I think it's incredible.
I remember a year or two ago,
Kubernetes came up somewhat
frequently.
I think now, within
the drone community,
almost every day someone is
installing Drone on Kubernetes.
I'm blown away and I
think, as a result,
we're spending a
lot more time trying
to integrate with Kubernetes
and make that a more
seamless experience.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, could
you tell us a little bit more
about, why Kubernetes?
Maybe Jessie knows about this?
Like, why do you
think Kubernetes
would be a good environment
to run such a thing as Drone.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah,
I think a lot of people
actually use Kubernetes,
most of the time, for CI
processes because you
have a bunch of jobs,
you don't really care
on which nodes they run,
you just need to
get it somewhere.
And it needs to complete.
So having the basic
scheduler there
to handle a bunch of jobs for
your corporation or something
is super nice.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure
the isolation is also
a nice factor, too.
JESSIE FRAZELLE:
Oh yeah, of course
because containers
isolate and then
you kind of have peace of
mind that team two is not
messing with team one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So, whenever I think
about a bunch of different
tasks that need to be processed,
especially for Kubernetes, the
first thing that comes to mind
is the Jobs API.
Are you using it?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So, right now--
we initially started
looking at the Jobs API.
And one of the
suggestions we got
was, instead of
using the jobs API,
to create custom
namespaces, one for each
build and then
inside that namespace
spin up pods with
persistent volumes.
And then, for each step in the
pipeline creating a new pod.
MARK MANDEL: So, for those
people who aren't familiar--
and I'll defer to you, Jessie--
what's a namespace?
What does that mean?
JESSIE FRAZELLE:
Yeah, so Kubernetes
has this concept of namespaces
where you can almost segregate
how your cluster is defined
in terms of where things are
running and how they run
in terms of interactions
with other containers.
So when you namespace
something, you're
blocking off network
traffic, stuff like that
from interacting with
another namespace.
And where we're even
getting to in the future
is where your security
model could be the namespace
as a boundary, which is
why it would actually
be great for Drone,
in this case,
because then maybe even
multitenant jobs not
in the same company could be
run on Kubernetes as a CI, which
would be really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So, basically, you
could say that it's one
more layer of isolation,
like, containers provide
a layer of isolation,
namespaces is like
a second one on top.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah, it's
just the more abstract layer
in terms of--
instead of isolation from
system calls of Linux
and stuff like that, you're
just one more layer up
of it's isolating the
parts of Kubernetes
that you don't want to interact.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: I think
the interesting thing, too,
about namespaces, you can
correct me if I'm wrong,
Jessie, but my understanding is
if you delete the namespace it
cleans everything up.
So, from a CI perspective--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's nice.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI:
--it's really nice
because you don't have to worry
about-- a pipeline might have
10 or 15 steps all creating
and spawning containers,
so the fact that you can
just, with one API call,
wipe all that out and not worry
about leaving artifacts around
on the system is really nice,
at least from an integration
standpoint.
MARK MANDEL: Probably
also means you're
less likely to accidentally
wipe off something
you shouldn't be wiping off.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah.
That's genius, actually.
I didn't think of
that as a feature.
It's like a hidden
feature, there.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: I didn't
know that was the thing.
I'm actually now really
excited about it.
That's cool.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI:
Credit goes to Kelsey
because he's the one
that told me that that's
what I should be doing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Dear coworker
Kelsey [? Hightower, ?] hello.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent, so
now I'm also just curious.
You said that for
using Drone you
write a Docker Compose file.
What is the developer experience
like when they use Drone?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Sure,
I mean, Drone supports
a lot of different
workflows, but I
think the most interesting
is Drone uses, like I said,
a superset of Docker Compose,
and in many ways behaves
like Docker Compose.
You can actually run
your build locally
just by running
drone exec and it'll
spin up-- let's say
you're using Docker
for Mac-- it'll spin up and
run your build in isolation,
locally.
So, gone are the
days where you're
pushing to your CI
server, seeing it fail,
updating your YAML, pushing
in kind of rinse and repeat,
doing that over and
over and banging
your head against the wall.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I've done that.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So, yeah,
I think it starts with that
and a lot of individuals
really like that workflow.
So then when you
push to something
like GitHub or
Bitbucket or GitLab,
Drone supports many
different providers.
Right now, everything
gets enqueued,
and Drone will pull
down the builds
onto one or many
machines and execute
the build by
interacting directly
with the Docker host
spinning up those containers.
And so the nice thing is you
have a level of determinism
because the build that you
executed from the command line
on your machine runs
the exact same way
in your CI environment
on your servers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I think it's time to go a little
bit more into the architecture.
You mentioned that it
is running Go-- yay!
You also mentioned
that it was basically
just like a Docker container.
Everything was
running on containers,
you can run it very
easily on Kubernetes.
What are the other
dependencies that you have?
Is there any other
dependencies-- like,
what do you do for
storage or communication
across containers?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Sure.
So in terms of dependencies,
the most important thing,
in my opinion, with
Drone is that it
ships as a single binary with
no hard, external dependencies
other than a container runtime.
And so that's important
because no one
wants to download and
install open source software
and then have to install 10
other pieces of open source
software.
But that being said,
Go makes it really easy
to do abstractions
with interfaces.
One of the goals is to ship
Drone with built-in modules
like a queue, like Pub/Sub,
like log streaming,
but to allow you to swap
those out with something-
and I'm going to use this
buzzword word, but something
more Cloud-native.
So, yeah, I know, right?
Everyone's laughing,
but I think that's--
and it's one of those terms
that's thrown around a lot.
And it's kind of lost a
little bit of meaning.
But for me, what I
want with something
that's considered Cloud-native
is you install the software,
you're running it, but
you can swap out modules
with things that are
going to scale that you
don't have to worry about.
So for example, Drone ships with
an internal in-memory queue.
But, using Go and
using interfaces,
you can swap it out very easily
with Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So I was going
to ask, you said using Go,
using interfaces--
is that using the Go
1.8 plugin system?
Or how are you
actually switching out
from one to the other?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So right now
we provide those baked in.
So right now if
you're using Drone,
you can use the in-memory queue
or the Cloud Pub/Sub queue.
Those are the only two we offer.
Maybe we'll look at the plugins.
It's a great and
interesting new feature.
So it's something we'll
definitely look into.
MARK MANDEL: Are you configuring
that through an environment
variable, or is
that how it works?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yep.
You just flip a few
environment variables
and then you're good to go.
And so then we can do that with
other modules in terms of you
got the queue, now
you have logging.
Drone has an in-memory
log multiplexer.
You can use stack
driver logging.
You can do that
with the EventBus.
You can use Pub/Sub
and another goal
is maybe using Kubernetes
as the back end
instead of in memory
or a local Docker.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And once you're able to
basically break that--
I'm going to use the
word monolith, that
monolith you mentioned that you
have one single static binary
build with Go into
more pieces, I
guess that you're also
thinking about the fact
that you can scale some of the
pieces independent of the rest?
What are your plans on that?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yeah, I mean,
I think that's the goal,
is letting the developer
pick and choose
what they want to scale
or maybe, as Drone grows,
it can kind of grow with them
by leveraging Google Cloud
and the services it provides.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm curious
about Jesse's opinion
on the definition
of Cloud-native
because I know that she
has opinions on this.
So what is Cloud-native for you?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: I was
actually just going
to joke that if you
say that one more time,
Eric Brewer is going
to show up here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cloud-native.
Hello, Eric.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: He's probably
somewhere around here.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah,
it's such a buzzword.
I think that it's just honestly
anything that you can deploy
in the cloud easily,
which is a lot of things--
and I think people just
kind of throw that around--
but also things that
are built into tools
that are the cloud like using
Pub/Sub, using integrations
into Google Cloud itself
is super Cloud-native.
I feel like a
salesperson right now.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: I agree.
I think we need to take
it one step further.
I think that's
what Cloud-native--
I said it one more time, sorry.
I think that's
what it should be,
I think it's all
about integrating
with those built-in
services that Google Cloud
Platform or maybe
other providers
have to offer to give you
that extra scalability
and maintainability,
and I wish we
were more strict with the term.
So that's kind of how I use it.
MARK MANDEL: Do you look at
it also from the perspective
of, it's elastic, right?
If you build certain
apps in certain ways,
they're very hard to scale
because they might have
dependencies on other things.
We look at things like 12
Factor Apps, that kind of stuff.
I think of that as well
when I think Cloud-native,
like I've built my app such
that, if it lives in the Cloud,
I can have 1,000 servers, I can
have 2000, I could have 10,000,
it doesn't matter.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Yeah,
and the scalability of it
and the fact that you
can tear down, spin it
up, a lot of that, I think,
comes from containers.
But being able to just clean
slate, just start from nothing
and go from everything is huge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, last time
we talked about Drone here
on the podcast
was because it was
a cool thing of the week, which
was because the New York Times,
they created--
is it a plugin for Drone so
you can deploy stuff directly
to App Engine, container engine?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Correct.
Yeah, so Drone has a
really nice plugin system
where every step in the
pipeline is a container
and that includes
plugins themselves.
So writing plugins is as
simple as putting a Bash script
in a container so they
can be really any language
and there's a really
low barrier to entry.
So the New York Times
created a number
of plugins including
Kubernetes plugins.
And Drone actually has
probably about five
or six different
Kubernetes plugins that
would work with Kubernetes
in different ways,
some more simple and
some more advanced.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, what is
the whole idea behind this?
It means that I can basically
have my YAML file that you were
mentioning at the beginning
and at some point just say,
whenever there's a
new change in my repo,
this is going to
call Drone, it's
going to create a new
image, new deployment.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yeah, correct.
So we have plugins for
Google Container Registry.
So in the case of
the New York Times,
they were pushing to Google
Container Registry They
had a simple plugin to do that.
And then, once it
was in the registry,
they used the Kubernetes
plugin and a spec file,
and they used that
to automatically push
the new image to Kubernetes
and auto-deploy it
to a number of
different instances.
And I've even seen
teams where they
were deploying pool requests.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice,
to smoke test it.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yeah,
to smoke test it
and so you do some really
interesting things there.
There's a lot of
interesting options.
MARK MANDEL: Well, from
those plugins like that
and you were talking about
having the Pub/Sub integration,
are there any
plans going forward
to be more integrated with
Google Cloud Platform?
What's the plans there?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: I think ideally,
all those different modules
we talked about, which is
queueing, which is eventing,
logging, those are all
common with a CI system.
You'll find them
in any CI system
and I would love to
be able to hot swap
out those with the Google
Cloud Platform features.
And one of the
biggest ones is I want
to be able to launch builds
on Kubernetes itself,
so instead of
interacting directly
with the Docker daemon, we can
use the Kubernetes scheduler--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI:
--to launch builds.
MARK MANDEL: So, there's been
a bunch of announcements,
there's been all sorts
of cool stuff going on.
What have been some highlights
for you from the conference?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: I think one
of the biggest highlights
was the community summit,
which gave us a chance
to connect with a lot of other
members in the community,
open source developers, and get
some insight into the vision
behind Google Cloud.
And I think, as an
open source maintainer,
the thing I want
most or look forward
to most is Google's
commitment to openness.
I think it's awesome
that Kubernetes
is being developed in the
open and given to the CNCF
foundation.
And I'm really interested to
see how much further Google can
take that.
As an open source developer, I
want to integrate with Google,
but I want to make sure I'm
not locking customers in.
So I'm really interested to see
how Google will take openness
to a next level in its Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: That was
a highlight for me
on the keynote, when we were
like, yeah, we want to be open,
we want to
[? have you ?] enter, we
want to have you
able to leave, but we
want to take our
chances on the fact
that we're just going to be
the best place for you to stay.
And that's a philosophy
that's definitely
near and dear to my heart.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, similar
question but for Jessie.
You've been here at the
conference, also, three days
already.
What was your favorite moment,
or favorite announcement
or whatever?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: I
guess I have two.
So my favorite moment was
that the keynote today was
all about open source
and being open,
and I obviously love that stuff.
But then I liked
the announcement
that [? Eris ?] gave with
regard to the security chip
for verifying the
BIOS of the servers.
I think that it's
really cool that Google
has this opportunity,
since we control
the hardware, to do that,
which not a lot of people have.
And it's super dope.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we
interviewed Cornelius Willis
and Neal Mueller from
Google Cloud marketing team
exactly about that and we
were able to actually touch
one of those Titan chips.
They're tiny.
MARK MANDEL: I tried
putting one in my ear.
JESSIE FRAZELLE: That's so cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool, well,
we're sort of almost
running out of time but
is there anything else
we haven't talked about
that you want to mention
before we wrap things up?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Regarding Drone
or Cloud-native or Cloud-native
or maybe other
Cloud-native or Cloud Next?
JESSIE FRAZELLE: Server-less.
Just kidding.
[EVERYONE OOHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: She went there.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: I
think the only thing
maybe worth mentioning that
I'm really excited about is--
I mentioned that we were
taking all these components
and modules in Drone and
extending them and actually
pulling them out of Drone.
And the cool thing is, as we do
that, it gives you the ability
to compose your own CI system.
So if you've ever wanted
to scratch your own itch
and build that CI
system, but you
didn't want to build your
own queue, your own message
bus, your own logger,
integrate with Docker,
integrate with Kubernetes,
your own YAML format,
you can actually pick
and choose those modules
and compose your own in a
surprisingly small amount
of code.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And all of
this code is, as we said,
open source and is at
GitHub.com/drone/drone.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Perfect.
MARK MANDEL: And that's
the perfect place
for people to get involved, they
should just go to the GitHub?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI:
Yeah, absolutely.
Log tons of issues.
Just kidding.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
about you, Jessie?
Anything else you'd like to add?
JESSIE FRAZELLE:
That's all, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great,
well, thank you so much,
both of you, for taking the
time out of your Cloud Next
experience to share
your experience with us.
JESSIE FRAZELLE:
This was fun, thanks.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Thanks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: An enormous
thank you to Brad and Jessie
for joining us.
Brad, great conversation about
CI, CD systems, containers.
Jessie, always a delight
to have on the podcast.
Really interesting stuff.
I really like testing and
testing infrastructure
and making sure that people
do that sort of stuff.
Obviously, I think
a lot of us do,
but having those infrastructure
tools available to people
as open source products
means that we can all
build really good systems.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, also
the explanation on namespaces.
I actually did not
know much about it
so that was very interesting.
OK, so let's go with the
question of the week.
And the question
of the week comes
from this guy that came to
get a podcast t-shirt from GCP
podcast booth at Cloud Next.
His name is Rokesh,
Rokesh Jankie.
I hope I pronounced
your name correctly,
unlike you who misspelled
your name in the email
you sent me, but anyway--
so his question is, OK, so what
is protocol buffers and why
should we all start using it?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
what is protobuf?
So, it is another open source
project that came from Google.
It's actually been
around for a long time.
What you can basically take
from it is it's an IDL.
It's an Interface
Definition Language.
So you write these protofiles.
And from those
protofiles, you're
able to basically
take the data that
is defined in those
protofiles and send it
across the wire in a variety
of different languages.
And it's a binary format
that goes across the wire.
So it's nice and small,
very performant, and super,
super cool that way.
The nice thing is
it's contract first,
so you're writing this
Interface Definition Language.
Your sender and your receiver
both have an understanding
of exactly the data they should
be getting and receiving.
So that's hugely powerful.
But it also gives you nice
things like versioning.
So if your data
changes, you don't
have to worry about it as much
between sender and receiver,
and do all sorts of
fun stuff like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, just to give
an idea of how
important this thing is,
we use it at Google for
virtually everything.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Whatever
we encode anything in files,
it's always protocol buffers.
Wherever we sending
data over the network,
it's always protocol buffers.
So it is, basically, we do not
use JSON internally that much.
Instead, we use
protocol buffers.
So you can see it like a
more efficient and easier
to collaborate way of
sending data around.
MARK MANDEL: If you're going
to play with protocol buffers,
I would definitely say have
a look at the gRPC project.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: It is the default
serialization and basically
core interface to gRPC.
We have two episodes that
we've talked about it on.
Episode number 15, we had Varun
Talwar, who is the PM on it.
And we also talked
with Brandon Philips
from CoreOS who talked about how
they use it internally as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and they use it a lot.
MARK MANDEL: They use it a lot.
So definitely well
worth the listen.
You can use protocol
buffers on their own,
but I think combined with gRPC
is just a really nice fit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and basically, gRPC,
what its going to do,
it's going to give you--
so if protocol buffers
defines messages,
gRPC defines the
operations that receive
and sends those messages.
Pretty much.
MARK MANDEL: Pretty much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
a way of seeing it,
and since we're talking
about protocol buffers,
there's also
another cool project
that I really like and I
discovered not that long ago.
It's called FlatBuffers.
Of course you've heard
about FlatBuffers
because video game
designers love it.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, I have
heard about FlatBuffers.
So FlatBuffers are literally
a slightly different way
of serializing data
up and down the pipe.
It still has an Interface
Definition Language.
But the thing that
makes it different
is that the data can
be accessed directly
without having to parse and
unpack it on the other end.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so basically,
the way I see FlatBuffers
is that in protocol buffers,
you need to decode the whole
message to get any of the data
inside.
In FlatBuffers, you
can just, whenever
you need that piece of data,
you access it directly,
which means that you're
doing, like, lazy decoding,
and if you have a
lot of information
and you want to just start
the game now, you can do it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so you
get different pros and cons
on each one on which side you
get the performance hit on.
They both work.
The cool thing is,
if you're using gRPC,
you can use FlatBuffers and
you can use protocol buffers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: It's up to you.
Awesome, well, I think
that's going to wrap up
another episode today.
Francesc, are you heading off--
I think you're still
going to GopherCon, China?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, I'll
being in GopherCon, China April
15th and 16th and I'm planning
to do some other things around.
Still not have decided so
I will not announce it yet.
And afterwards, I'll be
on my way to New York.
First week of April, I'll be in
New York for internal meetings.
So probably I'm going to
be planning some Go meetups
or Kubernetes meetups,
stuff like that.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So, as
I said before, I'm
heading off to Vancouver.
I've just had it
confirmed that I
will be speaking at the
Vancouver Unity meetup
talking about game
servers, actually
running on Kubernetes, which
is loads and loads of fun.
And then I'll also be talking at
the polyglot meetup on the 6th
as well in Vancouver.
We're doing--
[INAUDIBLE] Simon Says
talking about gRPS and
Kubernetes, strangely enough.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, but
after that, later in April,
East Coast Game
Conference and Vector.
I'll be there-- both
places-- as well, again,
talking about Kubernetes
and game servers,
having loads of fun there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, I think
it's time to say goodbye.
So thanks again.
One more week and it's
seventy weeks in a row.
Thank you for taking
the time to record
this amazing episode with me.
And thank you all out
there for listening.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
Francesc, thank you
for joining me once again.
And we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]